how're you guys hoping we're doing
pretty good I'm out in the woods with my
wife and our dogs they're staying
positive and trying to stay busy and
Tyler and I did a zoo songwriting
session today
so that was provided that's pretty cool
we did one last week and so you know
trying to try to have some normalcy and
continue to do what we do know for us as
creatives and as artists you know even
just playing guitar and writing music
and being able to kind of put your heart
out that way it really is therapeutic
you know and it really is something that
fortunately a virus can't take it away
from us
and you have another baby coming along a
baby boy congratulations thank you thank
you or uh we're excited and looking
forward to it no we're good Haley's
doing well she's a trouper I feel like
she's only known pregnancy for the last
three years so she's ready to not be
pregnant but she really is a trouper hi
my name is suni you're doing kids songs
all day you know what funny you should
say that we watched we watched frozen to
at least once a day if not twice a day
and trying to block it yo dude it's
serious I've been trying to block it out
but I find myself singing else's songs
or frozen songs more than any other non
or demo or anything I'm working on your
speedy open the Florida Georgia line's
fans will soon find themselves singing
along to the duo's latest single I love
my country from their upcoming fifth
studio album
[Music]
how refreshing is to have that song
right now don't you love it you know we
do we're so thankful to have that song
out we don't want to overthink it we
wanted to put something out that allowed
our fans and anybody to just kind of get
out of the moment of what the world is
going on with this world and things are
confusing times are weird but you know
here's a song to make you dance and get
outside your head we've had more fun
making this album through the process
and I think any other album